I gotta ask you big hit have you tapped
in with only fans since getting out are
you aware of only fans only only fans
some of the porn [__] yeah of course
because this was not a thing but you
wouldn't there was no only fans like a
girl who works at McDonald's could get
the [__] popping online there's teachers
who are teaching kids right now who are
also doing things on the internet for
extra money you know what I'm saying
it's a different world it's a hard time
out here it's not the days of maximum
magazine and all that [__] that shit's a
rap you know right right yeah have you
have you got have you signed up I didn't
sign up personally but nah uh I was on
PornHub y'all just go through it you
know what I'm saying yeah no pornhub's
wild for sure what's the go-to category
and porno yeah threesomes
big black [__] black [__] with ass
threes you know who I just saw like uh
did not age one do you remember Pinky oh
we gotta talk wait wait I forgot about
that that just reminded me I'm like
because I just saw this happen yeah
pinky all right I woke up this morning
and they flagged me and took my post
down I seen that like as soon as I woke
up this morning okay yeah I I did not
mean to bring up the porn thing and get
into your porn thing because I didn't
know this I just saw this like a couple
days ago yeah so you used to score porn
movies yeah so I was uh we just went
back to uh Pasadena and shot this Monte
Carlo video with Dom Kennedy and I used
to play it looked like it was just a
house party that was a party at the park
we were just kicking it yeah so my my
cousin used to uh like be a coach up at
the park we was at so I started thinking
about my cousin I was like damn this
thing used to direct like big time
pornos like he had did some [__] and he
used to buy Beats for me he was give me
like a thousand dollars I'm like 18
making My First Beats my like this I had
only been making beats for two years at
that point and he started cashing me out
for Beats he was doing it on a real
level you know what I mean so I just
thought about that pinky scene oh wait
so you have a beat back one of your
Beats is playing during a pinky scene
yeah I just I have posted it on my gram
and they took it oh you found the scene
I found the scene yeah oh God and that
[__] was going up online like and then
you know IG hated on me I guess because
the little nipples out or whatever I was
gonna say uh do you remember the name of
the DVD because this is the DVD it was
like it was like art Angels oh yeah she
was like painted and they had like a six
four out there like yeah that was oh
that sounds like a big production real
West Coast uh porno production do you
remember when Snoop dropped his porno
yeah for sure
I was like I remember thinking like
there's no way snoops on here for he
wasn't obviously but it was just like
the most random porno of all time and
they they just definitely you know my
cousin who was older than me bought it
because Snoop was on the car it worked
they made money oh yeah for sure yeah
there's a few rappers have done that I
think yeah uh no it's funny though
because uh hip-hop DX they made a post
and made it seem like I was actually in
the porno so I had to repost it and let
[__] know like nah they took my [__]
and put it in a whole different context
but it is what it is my cousin used to
invite me to the set since yeah I used
to see the [__] cracking like damn it's
a wild life yo pinky were you there for
the pinky shirt I wasn't no Pinky's a
legend she's also like a [__] low-key
or she's like a tiny little like seeing
like more recent pictures of her she
definitely looked different than she did
in them days but yeah you know shout out
to pinky she's a legend nonetheless yeah
um Reckless and Ratchet on there on
PornHub
yeah did you guys got to do a reckless
and Ratchet just branded
yeah why not we should perform that at
AVN or PornHub get at us yo hello
artists are doing the AVN Awards in my
face we should definitely perform that
that's a perfect song G-Eazy just did it
uh tiger did it a bunch of you know I've
been saying that for sure
um I I just saw price just dropped his
new album last Friday
um
what's going on with everybody else I
think octane's back to want to put music
out I just saw I've been seeing him drop
Clips yeah I mean you know everybody
doing their thing like price he he he
been like on a different level of
lock-in you know what I mean like he
stay tapping in with me we'd be chopping
it sending ideas and he didn't record it
on some new beats of mine within the
last few months too so I just say what's
up with like cat money and K Roosevelt
and bmac I mean yeah they they all doing
anything I thought bmac reached out when
we dropped Surfer Jones she showed love
you know what I mean can't money show
love it's just like everybody just doing
what they do locked in and I'm focused
on whatever what's K Roosevelt doing
he recording he uh you know if he play
instruments he locked in yeah that
shit's crazy he actually uh co-produced
the song with me on the music Soul Child
album that I dropped in March yeah he
produced co-produces song